magic c'est un nouveau cuisinier mon
avocat et mon maître à penser
il cuisine pour se calmer les nerfs
rendez-vous au frigo il faut que tu vois
mon canot qd elle à chaque note
correspond à l'alcool in ekker ou à la
roma
on l'obtient à douma stajic pour un
accord mineur tout à fait quatre fois ce
matin disons deux ou trois notes
personnelles vers eux
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un enfin c'est
comme tu es gaulin ce sentiment de
solitude
si j'existe de tomber amoureux une danse
est convenable ce soir chez bibi oui
mais si quand la voix la voix si oui
complètement ridicule parce que je peux
partir s'il vous plaît
ça
c'est un peu courant
ici le cas
je me sens pas bien voulais pas me dire
ce qui se passe je veux faire quelque
chose je suis pas le mari mais je fais
partie de l'équipe nous émeut phare dans
le poumon droit annonce de givre le
projet qui s'inquiète ans
j'ai ce sentiment que toute ma vie
dépend de cet instant précis je le rate
bon je pense là contre 1 tu as vite 10
en huit jours
très mal dit chloé qui vous à m
sur le moment on essaie celui d'après et
si on échoue on recommence instants
suivants on a toute la vie pour réussir